and the power of the internet all right
there we are we are live
with a titanic figure in my life and in
cosmology and astronomy dr john mather
senior project scientist of the james
webb
space telescope which has been in the
news for some reason uh we don't know i
mean maybe it's because uh john uh his
his chapter in in this book which he
doesn't even have a copy of into the
impossible uh this i'm going to send you
right after this interview john for
giving uh john how are you feeling how
are you doing right now
i'm great and i'm greatly relieved
because uh now that we've gotten to this
point
uh i'm just beginning to think of all
the things that were dangerous along the
way
everything that could have gone wrong
didn't didn't go
could have gone wrong didn't go wrong
but it still must have been incredible
and nervous we've survived everything
yeah well i wasn't nervous but maybe i
should have been other people were
because they were actually taking care
of all those things that i should have
worried about
and so
plenty of people were nervous doing
their job so
anyway yeah i'm so appreciative and so
thrilled that it worked perfectly it is
so perfect it's beyond
expectation it's it's almost beyond
hopes
so that
the optical quality is brilliant
so we promise diffraction limited
quality images at two microns wavelength
and it's almost twice as good as that
and john just from a human perspective i
believe you started working on this in
1995.
um i did
kobe was still going on back then how
did you how did this work for you what
was this career step like for you how
did you have the courage to do this and
what does it mean after almost 30 years
oh my goodness well kobe was just
finishing we launched the kobe in 1989
and we ran it for four years so
um
i was more or less finished with my part
uh by 1995 and i'm thinking what to do
next
and i was surprised i got a phone call
from nasa headquarters would you like to
work on this new mission we're starting
a study
and i thought absolutely this is the
coolest thing i've ever heard of i went
to work on this and i still think it's
the coolest thing
and that's saying a lot because kobe uh
changed changed my life because it
happened right when i was starting
graduate school back at brownsville
yeah it certainly did and it changed
your life too uh eventually you would uh
win a nobel prize with george smoot uh
for that work um did you have i know
like those of us that have children are
blessed to have children those of us
that are blessed to have more than one
child we always say when they're when
they ask us i used to ask my mom you
know we have there are four of us four
of us brothers say mom who's your
favorite kid she said that's like asking
me to choose my favorite arm and i'd say
mom you're right you're left-handed
you're left-handed mom come on uh
of all the stuff that that webb can do
do you have a favorite
well i just
i think taking pretty pictures is my
emotional favorite
so what's the science behind that well
the first objects that grew out of the
big bang material that's the
continuation of my fascination with the
history of the universe some things out
there that we didn't expect
i think so
so just recently we're just getting a
hint from theoretical predictions about
how the first gigantic black holes might
have grown
it's one of those top mysteries of
science we
detected the dark matter effects we
detected the effects of dark energy and
we still do not know what made the giant
black holes grow
we know little ones can grow from
stars that blow up
but we can't really figure out how the
big ones got there
and since there's a big one in the
middle of every galaxy that's a disaster
for a country's
we've got to deal with this so
we got predictions of course but now we
have to get pictures and data and so
that's one of our top challenges yeah
yeah indeed so i was able to take
take some questions from my audience of
over 100 000 people that are part of
this project that i call into the
impossible it's your second time on the
podcast and i'm so uh so grateful that
you took this time during this week we
only have about 20 minutes
before your next series of meetings but
um but i wanted to maybe start off with
just a personal question uh not personal
a question for me
when we look at the results and the
impact they're having on society as a
whole
what to what do you attribute this
fascination is it the pretty picture
phenomenon or is it really the the the
public has gotten accustomed to these
fantastic not only images but the data
from things like hubble and things like
uh all the other great nasa projects and
ground-based projects too what um what
do you tribute the the fascination of
the public this is so arcane and and it
took so long why is the public so
interested in this i
i think they're interested in the same
question i'm interested in where did we
come from
what's the history how did we go from an
expanded universe with the hot and cold
spots in it that we measured with the
kobe two here we are having our little
planet that's a nice place to live how
did that happen
and there's so many steps that
astronomers can work on
uh the formation of the stars and the
galaxies and the black holes and all
that stuff how did the planets grow uh
and of course we want to know and we
also really want to know are we alone
everybody wants to know that
uh my personal opinion is no we're not
alone but the neighbors are really far
away
in other words a good a good planet is
hard to find and even though we know
most stars have planets
and quite a few uh we have not found any
systems that resemble our own solar
system yet
which is to say uh three or four little
rocky planets in the middle then uh
for so big
uh cold gas giants way out there uh we
don't have anything like that to point
at in what we've found so far
so what's going on
our solar system might be special so
we know earth is already special here in
the solar system it's the only place
where we can live
and um so what's going on how come
there's a lot of mystery here
and of course we all want to know is
there life on mars
and we can find out by going there and
getting some pieces and bringing them
back
how about other places in the solar
system that are maybe possible like
europa where there's an ocean
under the ice or how about on titan
where there's uh lakes and rivers of
methane and ethane um
stuff could be happening that we could
find by actually bringing pieces home
and that would be even
maybe even more exciting than our
beautiful
pictures yeah exactly and actually that
dovetails nicely
with uh with the first question that i
received from one of my listeners and
just a reminder on my youtube channel dr
brian keating you can submit questions
uh for almost all my guests i always
give a preview of who's coming up next
and i had on uh
not maybe not so near neighbor to you uh
as well nearer than those aliens that
you talked about john uh and that was
bill phillips of uh nist in gathersburg
he was on recently i solicited questions
his episodes coming soon but first
question does involve planets and it's
from april van ryan and she asks my main
question is does webb have the potential
to see a small rocky planet close to us
and what is miri likely to see when
she's used to her maximum potential i
have a billion questions but those are
the first ones so i guess it's about
it's about mary and about the small
rocky planets the wasp 96b which uh you
did release uh spectrum of this week
your team uh is is a gas giant uh not
unlike jupiter as i understand it uh but
but can you see a small rocky planet
like the distance from the earth to the
sun
we can see them indirectly we see them
when they go in front of their star it's
called transiting
and
well here in the solar system we watched
venus do a transit across the sun a
little while back and the sun detect got
extremely tiny bit fainter for a little
while because some starlight sunlight
was blocked we do the same thing with uh
little planets way out there uh
we will several dozen planets in the
first year including about two dozen
little ones
uh but unfortunately for us the only
ones we can study are the ones that
orbit very small stars
uh m stars they're called and so the
planets are very in very close and it's
a pretty hostile place for a planet so
we'll study them um some people think
they will surely have atmospheres other
people think surely they will not
so we will be trying that experiment as
soon as possible in fact i'm not sure
when the first ones come up in the
schedule but it's pretty soon right so
we'll try that uh so the other thing she
was asking was about the miri
which is the mid-infrared instrument and
we will be using it for this transit
spectroscopy study also
um it is neither none of our instruments
are capable of seeing a little earth
orbiting uh
a sun-like star it's just too faint
but
we do have pretty good
performance for our coronagraphs which
enable us to see brighter planets
orbiting their stars so we are going to
be trying that we're obviously going to
try the obvious cases what about alpha
centauri
what about proxima centauri we will look
uh plenty of people think we won't see
anything but of course we have to look
yes that's right it's uh it's the wayne
gretzky principle you miss all the shots
you don't take uh so
but there's so many and then the
resolution's so phenomenal uh but i want
to go a little bit further out one of my
uh listeners or viewers rather jimmy
jazzy
asked the question
can webb rule out or comment on the
uniformity of the universe
exactly he's referring to the
cosmological principle there's been some
some claims recently by groups uh in
europe and other
other places that you can actually
potentially
have questions about how
much the the cmb dipole and the
distribution of quasars and other
galaxies align with that or don't
what about going to cosmology in a
survey sense is web equipped or
positioned in any way to look at things
and see potentially to comment on
whether or not the cosmological
principle might have some some need of
an update
good question um
we of course did not set out with that
as a major objective
we just said we will study everything
you can see with an infrared telescope
because it's all new
we got the pioneering observations with
the spitzer telescope um if you want to
answer questions about is every place in
the sky basically the same you need to
study a lot of sky
so the next big telescope growing up for
that purpose will be euclid from europe
and then the next one after that is ours
from nasa it's called
nancy grace roman space telescope it's a
2.4 meter diameter same as hubble but
takes a hundred times as much sky at one
bite
so it will be really good at surveying
to look for those cosmological questions
is every place really the same or is
there some funny business going on
um about the expansion so
too soon to answer your question but
um
yes uh so another listener uh is asking
a viewer hc traveler is asking um can
when will the trappist-1 system or will
the trappist-1 system be viewed by web
uh i think we're starting right away
because it's an obvious candidate i do
not remember for sure when the first
observations will be
you know we cannot see every target all
year
but i think i've heard that this one's
coming up soon
so uh how does the prioritization work
again you know thinking back to children
and you know we scientists are kind of
like children you know we we're curious
we're imaginative but you know we don't
play well with others we don't like to
share our toys with
how do you prioritize you know i mean
among all these phenomenal science goals
that you have equipment to look at how
do you prioritize today we're going to
look at this tomorrow we're going to
look at that
okay well of course we do it with
committees and that's the natural thing
for astronomers uh will horton will you
you have to send us a proposal brian if
you want to observe something with the
telescope you have to write it down send
us in for a discussion and you have to
prove that this is a good idea and that
you know what to do with the data when
we give it to you
and by the way you are supposed to tell
us everything about the concept but
you're not supposed to tell us who you
are
we want to review this with not without
knowing
whether you're
um
i don't know
we just want to be fair as much as
possible so one curious result of that
is that about 10
of the
proposals we chose were submitted by
graduate students so this is really
great for young people to get in uh we
welcome that
and it's uh it's a lovely surprise that
so many young people have succeeded by
by writing the best proposals
um oh and a quick personal choose which
organizations are going to get the
picture then you say now what time of
year are we going to observe it and so
that's governed by a calendar when are
they in the line of sight when can the
telescope point at that target
how long will webb last in an optimistic
uh scenario
how many years we
we
are expecting at least 20. uh we were
requiring 10 uh or even five we but we
got a really good launch a basically
perfect launch from the ariane 5
and so we didn't have to use any extra
fuel for compensating for its errors
and now it turns out we're not even
using up fuel as fast as we thought we
would so maybe even more than 20 years
is possible so
if you've just been born you might still
have a chance to use this telescope
that's right so some of our graduate
students graduate students hopefully
we'll be working on this our grand
students
wd ask a question uh thanks you for your
great service giving us eyes we've never
had before my question is now that jwst
is a reality are there any projects on
the horizon that not only will
self-assemble the way that uh
the web did but maybe you self-replicate
could you see a telescope factory in l2
the way that that that web is but making
other uh other telescopes for the future
is that even a conceivable possibility
well people like to speculate about that
and and we draw sketches of how we would
do it
um but so far it looks kind of fanciful
because we haven't gotten to the first
steps
uh everything we've done in space uh
required astronauts to put it together
so web is uh sort of the most elaborate
uh self-assembling thing we've done for
astronomy and it was pretty scary
because you know when you put it
together you say what if it doesn't work
oh my gosh what do we do then
and
that is so
well when we started it was impossible
now it is possible to get a rocket out
there with help
um but
um so we do design our next missions
with this in mind the possibility of
sending help
either robotic or human but at least
webb was done without that possibility
and that's pretty scary
yeah as you took the advice you went
into the impossible you did the
impossible uh missy car is a good friend
she's saying this is so great thank you
you're the coolest thing
uh the question is now about in our
solar system what can it do uh with
regards to say europa can we look at
europa and where is most of the
exoplanet science going to come from
with web is it images or spectrum
oh okay well first europa we will be
watching europa because it's got an
ocean with ice over it and there are
cracks in the ice where water comes
spitting out and we discovered that with
hubble
we will be looking at those same places
with the web to see can we see it with
infrared signals
and i don't know
just we will try it
um and why would we care well you'll
learn something with web but we're also
planning to send a mission out there
to fly through those plumes of water and
see do they have other molecules in them
like organic molecules
and i don't know whether they do or not
but personally my guess is that ocean
could be alive why not
and in that case look for complicated
molecules
uh so we'll do that
so the other question was more about
what are we going to observe
about exoplanets and
so we'll be working on the easy ones and
the hard ones the easy ones are the big
ones like the one we already showed um
where it's a big planet uh
and uh
obscures quite a lot of the starlight
and we already know that it's got water
in it
but when we say water we really mean
steam because that
planet
it's right in there close by to its star
and so
we will be looking at a wide variety of
these things some hot and some cold
some big and some small because
we just do not really know where to look
we should look at everything
don't just look where it's easy look
where it's hard
don't assume you know the answer of what
what the right place to look is as you
know everything about exoplanets was a
big surprise
uh when mayor and kalos looked at their
data to see if there was a planet there
they didn't expect it
other people had taken data and they
hadn't even looked at the data to see if
there was a planet in there because of
course who wants one of those we want
earth well there wasn't any earth in
that system but there were these other
remarkable surprises and everything's
been a surprise
so i don't know what the next big
surprise will be maybe it'll be all
those little rocky planets have
atmospheres maybe it'll be that none of
them do
and uh too bad um no that's you can't do
chemistry on nothing so
go build the next telescope that's what
that'll tell us
yeah there are questions about that too
maybe uh just just when we look out at
the you know current data it's just
astonishing to think that you started
working on this project in 95 and that's
when the first exoplanets were really
you know coming to the light of reality
and and so that wasn't as i remember
that wasn't really part of the original
mission design i mean of of web but it
kind of has become this this almost
unique niche that web can can accomplish
i i wonder john can you talk a little
bit about the partnership between
experimentalists like like you
uh and and and and observers but also a
theorist a question is coming in about
about that is there what kind of
tight-knit you know partnership i
remember on kobe from an outsider's
perspective you benefited tremendously
from the involvement of theorists um how
does that work with web how how do is
this still an opportunity for
theoretical contributions or is it um
basically they're gonna look at the data
and like everybody else how does that
work
okay well it's um sort of a lot of
different phases of a project
when uh an instrumenter like me says
well i've got an idea
oh that's cool that's just an idea well
why would you want to do that and then
you have to say
if you could do it what would you find
yeah um what might you find
what are the mysteries that that would
really address so
uh for that we need imagination we need
the people who have already done the
work of observing and they say well i
can't see far enough
or the people who do the calculations
see i imagine that this could be but how
can you tell
so we can't get the resources to build
that equipment unless you tell us to
so that's at the beginning then after we
do get along the ways then suddenly
theorists say i better predict what
they're going to see before they see it
so i can get my credit for my proper
kind of imagination and that happened
with the kobe satellite
when we started there was no period
prediction anybody could believe
by the time we launched there were some
really good predictions and some people
got it right what we would see
other people were completely amazed they
thought oh that can't be right
so
when when we published the map of the
anisotropy with the hot and cold spots
there were a few people that had a
uh pre-written scientific paper that was
only waiting for the information to come
from our data release and in a day they
had it submitted
so
we expect some of that for the web as
well um we know we told people what data
we would take uh and when and they will
be ready to plug it into their papers
and say here we are we know what that
means
so john i know you only have about five
minutes left i want to be so respectful
of your time uh we have so many
questions people are just so delighted
that you're taking your time and you're
you've always been a public servant in
such a wonderful way both as an
inspiration to young scientists like
when i was young i'm not young anymore
but but my current students but also to
the public you do such incredible
outreach i want to commend you for that
because not all scientists do that i
always make fun of science i say you
have a moral obligation to be uh to do
outreach to my fellow colleagues i want
to do kind of rapid fire just because
there's so many questions that are
coming in andy oates he's a very good
friend of the show he asks is there a
chance that the first definitive
detection of an exo moon could come from
jwst
oh i would love it but i don't expect it
okay um i don't know how you do it
i know theoretical predictions have been
made but i don't think anyone predicts
that we could be able to do it this is
really really hard yeah
and
some claim it's important to the
establishment of life that we have the
moon to block you know asteroid impacts
and so forth so who knows uh it may keep
the neighbors even farther away from us
uh gunner mcstabby which is kind of
scary name he asks are there models of
what looked like smacks what what the
smacks cluster would look like uh in
previous uh uh previous years uh versus
today is there any way to to do a
differential between these very distant
galaxies and see how many more galaxies
or the universe is the universe
producing more galaxies that we could
see from the web data that you have okay
well i don't know about that specific
place but we do have movies
that are made by super computers
you say i know how the universe started
i've got the hot and cold spots i know
gravity works this way
um
start the computer running and simulate
everything and you can get beautiful
movies of how the galaxies grow
and
and we have gotten pretty far with that
project
not only can you make movies about how
the galaxy stuff would grow but you can
even now make simulated web telescope
images
since a web telescope image is not a
movie it's a sort of snapshot of pieces
of the universe at all different times
from now all the way back as far as you
can go into the distant past so
uh superposition of movies of different
places
all seen in one picture so we can do
that now and
someday somebody will be able to answer
this question well but not today
uh it's a question coming in again from
ollie wright who's a good friend uh this
bears more on uh on the guest who's
chapter one in this book
and that is our good friend adam reese
uh so you'll get your copy i'm gonna
send this out immediately your chapter
your chapter eight but uh but adam is
very interested in the hubble tension so
ollie's asking are there are there
observations planned that will weigh in
on the so-called hubble tension from
webb
absolutely it's a top priority and item
of course has proposal in i'm not sure
when it's scheduled uh it's a hard
project um because what you have to do
is survey the universe even more
accurately than we've done before
so web has the capability in principle
to do this
but it requires so many steps
this is a
curious situation where we use the
brightness of objects to determine how
far away they are but now you have to
establish that you know how bright they
really are
and so this is a pretty tricky problem
so adam's working on it so his
competitors yes exactly we will see what
they get
the way things usually go is we do not
resolve the tension we just get
more and more assured that we're right
and the other person is wrong
but eventually we'll find out
so in the last minute that you have uh
john there's a question do you have
advice to people in the field uh just
starting out maybe young graduate
students um or even undergraduates do
you have any career advice we talked
about that in the last interview i'll
put a link to john's previous interview
and of course to the book
as well but do you have advice to young
people just starting out in astronomy
yeah um
i would say that our field is changing
rapidly
as new technology comes online and so
you can't really say i know what i'm
going to work on
uh in 10 years because it probably
hasn't been invented yet
so
um try to get in on the latest wave of
things and you may get catch that wave
and uh like i've said uh graduate
students can propose successfully to
observe with the web telescope so don't
assume you can't do it just because
you're young just give it a try see what
happens
that's my motto in life give it a try
and see what happens
yes and uh so john i want to thank you i
know it's uh it's 10 a.m out there
you've got another uh important meeting
hopefully we'll come back maybe in a few
months when we have more phenomenal data
from the james webb telescope for now i
want to thank you this is uh john mather
who's been a titanic figure in cosmology
you know i see me there's john and
here's a picture uh john you'll be
getting this book signed copy along uh
with something
from yours truly
and there will be many other
investigators to tell you stories about
what is found with the web
many other people that know more about
their topic than i can can ever know so
it will be fun for you too thank you so
much thank you brian it's been such a
pleasure bye everybody tune in next time
bye guys thanks john